[Music]
hi everyone
so we're going to take a look back at
the past 10 years of r
i started getting to r about maybe 13
years ago
and when i finished grad school i
discovered there was an r meetup in new
york city
and that's sort of my beginning of my
journey and it's been about 10 years
since then and
a lot of things have changed so we're
going to look at our
retro respectively in a few different
ways we're going to start with the
community
and see how that's changed a lot so this
particular meetup it was back then
called the new york r meetup
started on april 2nd 2009.
21 people rsvp'd and far fewer attended
it was founded by josh reich who went on
to find to
found banks simple ten years later for
our 10th anniversary
we had a meet-up in april within three
hours
40 people had signed up it was sold out
in less than a week
and our only constraint now is space we
are physically out of room to hold more
people who want to come
so the 10th anniversary we put up this
graph here showing our membership growth
zoomed in it looks like this i created
this graph originally for our 10th
anniversary
and we went from 21 people to 10 697.
since then we're now at 11 205 as of
this morning
so about a thousand people a year joined
the meetup
this is a picture from the first meetup
in fact there might be someone in this
room in there and
it was a small crowd and we had a ton of
space to work with here
because not that many people showed up
about 10 years later
it turned into this we have a lot more
people coming now
and we also take really epic selfies
so beyond the new york arm meetup which
i'm obviously partial to which is by the
way no longer called the new york r
meetup it's the new york
open statistical programming meetup
which is a lot of words
because it's r and friends it is a
friendly community of many different
open source languages
and around the world there's a map i
there's a
great shiny app out there that's showing
a map of all the different r meetups
around the world
and as of this morning there were 913
meetups
with over 700 000 members this did not
exist 10 years ago
something else that didn't exist 10
years ago was our ladies
it's a remarkable the growth that our
ladies have shown
and the turnout they do for all of our
events and this map shows 186 our lady
groups around the world
with over 62 000 members it's amazing
the growth of this community it didn't
it was not this large
so large in fact this morning there's
over 2 000 people in one room for this
conference
as think about that 2 000 people coming
to a conference about r
so what about what goes afar all the
stuff that goes around it
the growth of crayon has been amazing i
know it looks like a similar graph i
showed before but it's different data
now
about 10 years ago there were roughly 2
000 packages available on cran
there are now over 16 000 packages
there are 16 000 add-on packages to make
your life better
so you could use r better than you did
ever before so we really have to thank
cran for this
crayon has done such an amazing job of
curating not curating our packages but
making them accessible to us and
exposing
exposing them in a way that we can all
get easy access to and know that they're
good packages and their secure packages
how we use r itself has changed
drastically too this is the old
interface
who remembers this interface right
it was awful you entered code in one
line at a time and if you made a mistake
you had to start all over again
if you got sophisticated maybe you wrote
it in a text editor like notepad plus
plus or textmate
then you copy and paste it into r by
flipping back and forth it was awful
we're all here at this conference we all
know we have rstudio now
it's so much better it has a text editor
built in it shows your environment your
files your plots
and obviously a much needed dark
background
otherwise how do you have street cred at
a coffee shop when you're programming
so let's take a look at the code the old
code versus the new code and then and
now
because life was much harder back then
i had to walk uphill in the snow both
ways without save points
so as a convoluted example
we're going to look at how you can call
multiple functions repeatedly in a row
we're going to take from a data frame
the fourth row of the data frame
using just the head and tail functions i
don't think you should ever do this
outside of bash
but it's just to illustrate a point so
ten years ago i would have written
tail of head of iris comma n equals four
close my parentheses comma n equals one
and remember n equals one goes with tail
whereas n equals four goes ahead
you read it inside and out inside out
like a nested excel formula
and to be honest like almost every other
programming language is read
thankfully we have the pipe now iris
piped into head with n equals four piped
into tail of n equals one
we can speak the code we read it from
left to right it's very natural
but i don't think i need to convince
anyone here of the merits of the pipe
so let's talk about working directories
and paths one of the toughest subjects i
have when teaching
it is very hard to explain to people
who've lived in a gui world
so i'm going to list all the files that
were in a directory called data
that's two directories back so i would
use the list.files function
go dot dot slash dot dot slash data
to go backwards two steps and move
forward and this works fine
but if i'm doing this in the console it
works one way
but if i'm using our markdown that's in
a different folder it has a different
working directory it works a different
way
and i used to jump through so many hoops
to make this work out
and plus list.files by default only
gives the file name so it doesn't give
the path to the file
name so if you then try to read in these
files it's where are these files i don't
see the path
so two big improvements today we have
the dur
ls function from the fs package which
gives you the full path to the files
but the here package with the here
function
this allows you to combine the merits of
both relative paths
and absolute paths it dynamically
creates absolute paths on the fly
so your code works whether it's in the
console
or whether it's in a markdown document
and it's really nice
let's read in a csv next
read.csv has been around for a long time
i've given my old-fashioned path
i read it in and i get back a data frame
of course it's the data frames it tries
to print out all the rows all the
columns
i don't know what the types of the
columns are and in particular
the text data i don't know what that's
going to be
if we look at the class of the text data
it's a factor
by default read.csv converts character
data into factor data
unless you know to do strings as factors
equals false
and you do it without typos like you
don't remember that it strings plural
and it's camel case
and i learned that argument way too late
in my career
they did not teach that in grad school
so nowadays we have read underscore csv
you pass it into file name in this case
i use the here function to make it a
nice path
and it prints out right away it tells
you the different column types you're
getting
and it does not do strings as factors
it's by default turned off
we go to print it out and we see it's a
tibble
which is new zealand for data frame
and it smartly just shows the first few
rows the first few columns it shows the
data types
and has some other formatting niceties
and importantly to stress it it does not
convert your characters to factors it
leaves them alone
so getting columns let's say we want to
get a subset of the columns
well 10 years ago i used the aptly name
subset function
give it a data frame then you give it a
vector of column names
notice there are no quotes it was an
early days non-standard evaluation
and this worked on both rows and columns
but there's a problem
if you ever read the help menu for
subset there's a warning
it can have unanticipated consequences
how can they have that as a function and
not expect it to work a certain way
so you say well you know what i'll use
square brackets
so you write out your data frame square
brackets leave the first entry blank
because it's
you're taking all the rows then you pass
in a vector of column names as
characters and you get your two columns
awesome right and this syntax works just
as well in a tibble
if you want to use square brackets you
can and it will smartly just print out
the first few rows because it is a
tibble
but something i didn't learn in grad
school was that if you give it one
column
it returns a vector instead of a data
frame
i never got taught that so i had all
this code like oh sometimes there's two
columns sometimes there's one
it's a data frame it's a vector so i
wrote all sorts of
code to be like take the transpose of
the transpose of my subsetting
yeah then it was a matrix and it was
disgusting
so not consistent cost me hours and
hours so if someone had told me about
drop equals false
i would have been fine why is that not
the default
i know there's obviously good reason 30
years ago but not anymore
so we look at our modern table and
we select a single column it gives us
back a one column
data frame but if you want to set drop
equals true for some reason you can and
which is not the default and that's very
important
sensible defaults go a long way but
let's forget about square brackets let's
use d
plier we pipe our data frame into select
passed it the column names without
quotes and it's nice and easy to use
it's easier to write
if you select one column you get back a
one column data frame as you would hope
if you want a vector you could use pull
to get that column as a vector just like
putting a single name in square brackets
does which is confounding
and if you want to combine pipes and
square brackets you're more than welcome
to
square brackets is just a function that
you can pipe into
you surround it with back ticks and it
works like a function don't know why
you'd want to do it but you can
so let's now select a bunch of rows
based on a logical condition
we take our data frame square brackets
in the first argument we put we put a
vector with a logical condition
in this case data frame dollar column
so we have to refer to the data frame
pizza base
multiple times of course if you know me
there had to be a pizza example in here
so using modern technology we pipe
into the filter function we only need to
say the data frame once
and we just use the column name bear
this becomes more important when you
have
multiple conditions so we want to have a
condition on two columns
we have to say pizza base three times
pizza base square brackets pizza base
dollar price greater than equal to three
and pizza based dollar sign city equals
new york that's a lot of repeating
yourself
with filter we have pizza modern
pipe it into filter and you just use the
column names you don't need to repeat
the data frame
it's clearer you get a focus on the
logic that's really important
so if you want to select both rows and
columns
simultaneously with square brackets
you do your data frames square brackets
your logical condition which involves
the data frame name again
comma the columns you want and you hope
it's more than one column so remember
drop equals false
with dplyr we get to
do each step on its own line its own
function we take the data frame
we filter it then we select it
so let's see how plotting has evolved
there's been a lot of changes over the
past year in plotting
for example we're going to start the
example of the diamonds data set
because it's canonical at this point
this is a base graphics scatter plot
you can argue about its aesthetic looks
how if it looks attractive or not
but i first had to define the colors i'm
going to use i had to know how many
colors i wanted
i used the formula interface for plot
pass it a data frame the formula
interface is actually kind of nice
but then i need to provide the color so
i take my colors vector and i
subset it based on a vector from the
data frame using square brackets
then i manually add the legend and
hopefully everything lines up
i spent about an hour and a half
building this plot i forgot how to do it
and back then gigipod existed but it was
far from dominant
in fact lattice was giving it a run for
its money and i'm not going to show you
a lattice example because i've never
successfully made one of my own
so we have ggplot everyone here knows
the syntax probably loves it
you have ggplot pass it a data frame
pass it aesthetics give it a geom
it can do just about anything we have
fine grain control
we have great defaults even though i'm
not using the default theme
it's just easier
then we come to box plots now i'm not a
huge fan of box plots
because the box represents 50 of the
data which means the thin little line is
half of your data so you're throwing out
half of your data
but it's easy box plot give it a formula
give it a data frame you're done
but we could do better with violin plots
i take a violin plot i jitter the points
underneath them
i add some color to the points i throw
in my quartile lines
and i get to see both the shape and
density of the data it took a lot more
code
but i'm able to see what's happening in
the data i get a real sense i can really
tell a good story now
so we come to our favorite
one-dimensional data plot histograms
the hist function not histogram but hist
because you want to save characters
i pass it a vector as a data frame i do
data frame dollar column
it's basic it's unattractive it's not
great
if i do ggplot i can get a lot more
control
i can make the aesthetics look a lot
nicer and it's just a better plot
and if i want to there is no shortage of
interactive graphics
the high charter package lets me call
hchist
i still have to pass it in a data frame
dollar sign column
but look how great this is and if you
open this presentation your browser you
can hover
and use this interactively all the
simple line of code
and if you have time series you can call
the plot function
the plot function is overwritten it does
so many different types of plots
depending what object you pass to it it
gives you different plots you need to
know that
you pass it a multi-multiple time series
and it gives you a multiple time series
plot which is you know kind of nice
i'm not going to say it's attractive but
if you have
the forecast package or the fable and
feast packages
you can say auto plot and you get what i
consider a much much more attractive
plot
than you do with base graphics all with
still one line of code
and if you want to go interactive high
charter does it or
die graphs is another great package for
interactive time series plots
so let's aggregate some data let's do a
group by summary
if you use the aggregate function you
pass it a formula with the column you're
going to compute on the column you're
going to group by on
you pass it a data frame you pass it a
function it works but it's kind of slow
with deployer you have group by you have
summarize it's much more readable it's
faster
it's more sql-like so it makes a lot of
sense to a lot of people
and it works on database and spark back
ends so it's really versatile
if you want to aggregate on two columns
if aggregate
you need to use c bind on the left-hand
side of the formula
i don't know who thought of this i did
not know how to do this for years it was
so confusing to me why am i c binding
two columns that are in a data frame
now summarize you just pass it to
calculations and you're good
modeling has changed a lot too it
changed so much
it became machine learning
and then it became ai
so we start of r's formula and this is
powerful
traditional model formulation this is a
powerful tool in fact
r won a statistical computing award for
the formula unless you express your
outcome
and your inputs in a very nice fashion
you could call operations on individual
columns
it automatically creates dummy variables
for you it's amazing
but it's been overmatched by wide data
and it doesn't really help you when you
have new data you're trying to predict
on
so now we have the recipes package it's
a modern design matrix calculations
it's highly programmatic you list out
all the steps you're going to take you
can list individual columns
or you can say all numerics are all
outcomes or all
nominals you can create dummy variables
you use the prep function
to get all the calculations ready and
use the juice and bake functions to
carry them out
i think max went a little overboard of
his food analogies here but it works
so let's go fit our linear model lm it's
easy
it's tested it's fast it's really fast
it's written in fortran you're not going
to get much faster
call lm pass it a formula pass it a data
frame you're done
well using parsnip it looks like it
takes more code and it does
be declared that you're doing a linear
regression you set your engine to be
lm and then you fit the model to fit
function
the key part here is lm we're telling to
use lm
if you don't want lm if you want to go
all bayesian is the same as that code
except you change set engine to stan and
now you're doing mcmc for free
if your data is already in a cluster and
you want to use spark just
set it to spark it's that simple
if you want to do penalized regression
my favorite algorithm you say set
glimnet
if you want to do a neural network to do
a linear model you can because a single
layer neural network is a linear model
you just say set engine keras it's all
the same
speaking of neural nets everyone's
favorite algorithm
it's been in r for decades the net
function was written by brian ripley and
bill venables
it takes a formula like lm along with a
data frame it only has one hidden layer
but you tell it the size of that layer
and you have a
you have a neural network today's neural
networks take a lot more code
now it's amazing you can use tensorflow
but look at all this code it takes to do
the same function as earlier
and you have to compile in place you
modify in place it's a little weird for
our users
but you can get it's slower than the
neural network in r the
base r well at the end that package but
you can get much more complex
relationships
getting help has changed a lot too
sometimes you need some help
so back in the day you might turn to the
r help list and you might get a gem like
this
once you appreciate that you have
seriously misread the page things will
become a lot clearer
i'll let you guess who did that
or you might be welcome to or you might
respond to that with
hopefully this one isn't in the manual
or i'm about to get shot
scared face it wasn't friendly
nowadays we have nice people like mara
on twitter giving free advice
helping you out in the friendliest way
possible it's really amazing how much
better it is today to get help you don't
have to be
worried about someone's flaming you in a
mailing list
so it's a lot has happened in 10 years
quite a lot
and i've been thinking about my future
in r
and how i welcome the newest r
programmer to my family
and that shirt is a baby themed
hex sticker
we take our seriously in this family we
have the tiny verse
messiah burpar gigi poop
yeah and you know he has lots of our
t-shirts and we match a lot
so thank you very much
[Music]